see the weather report for the weekend
it's fantastic
better than Rome so what have you got
planned I don't know getting the garden
back in order followed by the first
barbecue of the year
having family and friends around or an
egg hunt or lying underneath the truck
while locked to its props our super
gluing yourself to a piece of public
property or closing down a bridge
causing inconvenience to half a million
people the seemingly mostly middle-class
eco-activists temper tantrum known as
extinction rebellion came to London and
shut down much of the city as
unforgivable as it was unbelievable
police spent the first 24 hours as
spectators and took no action as rows
were closed and others rights to live
their lives or earn a living were denied
look measured protest is one thing this
attempt to as one campaigner let slip
quotes go straight to the heart of
capitalism to overthrow it is
unacceptable after all nothing says save
the planet more than smashing the glass
doors of a fuel company does it there's
quite a lot to pick up on you I mean of
course we all agree with you it's
absolute madness that a bunch of
protesters brings London huge capital
city to a standstill they're not reading
the room at all on this one people have
to get to work and you know when you
hear part-time choir masters say things
like we're going to run out of food in
12 years and the nonsense that some of
them have spoken given that actually our
record on climate change in the UK is
pretty good they do have their wish list
which is to cancel carbon emissions
entirely by 2025 and so on and so forth
so that at least they've outlined their
goals but my goodness the means they are
using to try and achieve their goals are
so kind to productive I would argue it's
a own goal but Nick there's nothing
wrong with being middle-class there's
not yes they all rachels and peers and
talk wins and you are probably among the
more liberal
that power would suggest I would imagine
if there's a lot of it might come from
you have they misread this I completely
sympathize with their cause I completely
agree with what they are trying to do
but I think they're going about it
completely the wrong way and I think
Rachel's right they've lost the room and
also my problem with the protest is
there isn't a proper take away or to do
actually you're gonna going to bring
London to a standstill then tell us what
we're supposed to be doing
they have said they said they want us to
plant Parliament and and replace it with
a some kind of citizens thing and they
want to end capitalism that's that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
what are they wanting the public to do
to help us realize our goals as they
have exactly made it impossible she's
public so what else do you do yeah
decision makers and lawmakers are on
their recess people such as what they
what timing to choose right the
country's on Easter holiday Parliament
is in recess and one thing they have
achieved is they have got everyone's
attention that they've achieved but and
here's a big but we are such a wonderful
democracy one of the eight parts of our
democracy is the right to peaceful
protest but not the right disruptive
protest yeah and I took part I took part
a month ago in in the people's March a
million people for people's vote to do
with brexit now that was with warning it
was on a Saturday it was organized it
was very peaceful yeah and it dispersed
straight away within ours not that is
peaceful demonstration at its best in
this country maybe proud of this mob
this disrupting a whole country
disrupting a city disrupting work
disrupting people it is so bad and I'm
not sure how much they know about
climate change in a written as that the
vanguard of climate change to suggest
we're doing nothing is farcical we have
the most draconian set of rules in place
for carbon emissions we actually that
last year reduced our carbon emissions
by two percent you know where the lowers
that we've ever been 420
120 years to at the lowest ever be but
what a shameful for me in all of this is
the coppers role in all of this and and
the London Mayor Sadiq Khan
I know you've got I know you've got a
thing on that but yesterday dude he
might be supporting it today but
yesterday he was actually congratulating
the protesters and saying thank you very
much for being so peaceful well we have
we have a bang you can in a minute but I
just want to make my point
but the police force are standing by
while these people are gluing themselves
to trees doing absolutely well first
before me maricon I wanted to come back
on two of your points to us in terms of
the police this is what they had to say
we need to ensure we are striking the
right balance between the right to a
peaceful protest and keeping disruption
to communities to a minimum we are
mindful of the impact the demonstrations
are having on local communities and are
working hard with partners including
Transport for London to keep London
moving and open for business and
visitors alike now what you say about
Sadiq Khan is not true it is we I heard
here's what he had to say I'm concerned
about the difficulties workers are
facing to get to work the challenges the
businesses are facing but also the
protesters are now targeting public
transport our tubes are used by about 5
million people on a daily basis our
buses by 6 million and the best way to
address the issue of climate change is
people to be encouraged to use public
transport to walk and cycle so
inadvertently that the protesters are
driving people away from public
transport to use mini cabs and other
things let's move to a great show I want
to bring you in and I never thought I'd
say these words perhaps the lesson
should be if you look at the power and
that has been gained by the LGBT Lobby
who have never shut down bridges who've
never shut down roads who through soft
powers are incredible I think all right
I think broadening this out I think it's
absolutely pointless to be destructive
disruptors rather than creative
destructors as current said and if these
people are really serious I think they
should campaign as they are claiming
that climate change is going to very
much affect children and grandchildren's
future let them campaign to lower the
vote to 16 so they these children can
have a chance
I say in what government does and
actually can we just hear what
government is doing on this illness
matter the Dept of business and
industrial strategy has said this we've
seen firsthand the impact climate change
is having on our environment and we
share people's passion to tackle this
issue and protect our planet few
generations as a country as Carol says
who we've taken a world-leading action
to combat climate change but we are
going even further which is why we've
asked our independent climate experts
for advice on an ear sorry a net zero
emissions target and set up plans to
transition to lower emissions vehicles
and significantly reduce pollution
through our clean air strategy in a way
this whole thing is pointless because
that the government's climate change
committee has already been tasked and
they're going to be reporting within a
couple of weeks so and they will say
maybe it's not 2050 it's certainly not
going to be 2025 that is completely
unrealistic but here's another point
about the police you know the police are
completely understaffed they've been cut
by 22,000 no no really and they've gotta
deal with this just now just now we had
the report that attempted murders have
gone up and the violent crime has gone
up and they're dealing with destruction
right in that our police his point is
our police are understaffed so therefore
these protesters should not be
disrupting our city like this because we
need them to be dealing with much more
serious issues then the police officers
we do have have to be effective and
there is video going around now and if
they're in costume it's extraordinary
Sophos as dancing with the protesters
June please I didn't ask I want them to
enforce the 1986 Public Order Act which
makes it an offense to block the queen
or Kings Highway instead of dancing with
these protesters they should carefully
and respectfully round them up and gain
access to your carnival they often have
people people dress up if you look at
most
yes they should be doing important work
in in dealing with serious violent times
well that's not actually not dealing
with a destruct I'm Ike let's hear from
one of the protesters Carroll then to
you this is somebody who decided to
chain themselves or rather padlock
themselves to a truck I looked myself
unto the lorry just to make sure that it
doesn't get taken yeah so as long as
possible why are you here what's the
message today we're trying to say that
there's a massive crisis there's an
emergency that's not being seemed tune
it's not being managed by our
authorities critics are saying that
you've caused huge disruption to
ordinary Londoners what do you say to
those critics why do you think it's
still worth it
yeah I mean I totally understand that
that position really sorry to create
that disruption
I don't really movie under a lorry for
ten hours but I mean if you look at it
really clearly the dire consequences are
going to be so much worse Sky News Helen
and Smith was asking the questions I
know how she feels horrible
these protesters go to the heart of
where the carbon emissions vary why on
the streets of Beijing where where and
perhaps their carbon emissions yeah by
60% of in China and over the last 10
years but they won't go there or even
America they won't go there with it
because the live will be shorter water
candor thrown in jail forever in a day
but the bottom line is Sadiq Khan
whatever you say June has lost control
of this city it would put up with this I
can't imagine another appointment you
made an important point that 50 percent
of all the carbon emissions is from
three countries America China and India
we as a country have done really well
well it's like 1% of our population and
we're about 1% and we're doing a lot
yeah and we should be proud of that and
there is awareness amongst youngsters my
13 year old daughter said without this
protest well before this protest Oh dad
we don't do something countries like the
Maldives will be under water yeah so
they're aware of it okay other days
program about this put anyway